hello
i think we're live
welcome again to uh study with me
here uh as we
proceed in our 90 day challenge at least
some of us and i share with you uh some
of the things that i'm doing and my
approach to learning languages and my
approach to this uh 90-day challenge my
attempt to achieve a breakthrough
in oops i forgot to
share with you mute that okay
um so today i want to talk about
you know the importance of getting
outside our comfort zone
all right now
i think that's extremely important in
language learning it's extremely
important in life itself um
you know we can only learn by doing new
things
if we simply stick with what we know we
aren't
exploring new things we aren't gaining
new knowledge uh so this idea of getting
outside your comfort zone i mean it's
it's you know going into the water for
the first time to swim
learning to ride a bicycle
uh exploring new languages um
learning new skills
there's always the chance of failure
there's always a chance that we won't
succeed at this new
venture
uh but to do anything to achieve
anything we have to get outside our
comfort zone
and that's very much a part of language
learning because
if we just speak our own language you
know we speak it
however well we speak it we speak it
we're comfortable we can say what we
want to say we don't sound childish we
don't sound stupid
um we can speak but once we get into
another language of course we're outside
our comfort zone
at first we don't understand anything
and for a long long long time maybe
forever we don't understand it as well
as we understand our own language we
don't express ourselves as comfortably
in another language as we do in our own
clearly learning a language means
getting outside your comfort zone
even in terms of
these in language learning i think we
have to push ourselves to get outside
our comfort zone now for some people
this means overcoming the fear of
speaking
uh
and of course it is true that when i
start speaking for the first time and i
have a discussion at 11 o'clock in
arabic and tomorrow i have a discussion
in farsi and persian
of course
yeah i'm struggling to find words
uh i'm disappointed that i can't remo
remember more of what i think i know
i'm confusing persian and arabic
lots of things there that potentially
could make me feel uncomfortable i have
to admit i don't really feel
uncomfortable i rather enjoy the
experience it's really not a problem but
for some people it is
uh certainly many people report that if
they're in even if they can speak to
people in the language one-on-one if
they're in a group they have trouble
understanding i have myself been in the
situation where with uh where i'm with a
group of people speaking this other
language and of course i'm a little bit
afraid to jump in there and say
something because i feel i don't have
enough time to get my point across and i
won't say it properly and
and so it's more stressful one-on-one is
more comfortable it's easier especially
if it's a tutor the pewter tutor's going
to wait
for you so you're not under any pressure
to say what you want to say but getting
outside your comfort zone is also
important when it comes to content and
so i'm going to share with you some of
the things that i've been doing
so in persian i'm still kind of at the
beginning stage very happy that i can
say a few things speaking much earlier
than i spoke and many of the other
languages that i've learned and i i
credit the many stories and just the
fact that link is working much better
by the way the even the longer lang
lessons are coming up much faster now
everything that goes faster and easier
is good for us as we explore you know
outside our comfort zone but in arabic
now i have spent so much time with easy
material
and and i find the difficult material so
difficult that i kind of retreat back to
the easy material
and the result of that is that both in
arabic and
persian i've started speaking earlier
than i did say in czech
however my vocabulary isn't growing as
quickly and this is always the sort of
uh
you know the decision we have to make
the trade-off you know if we really
improve our ability to say a few things
then we aren't growing outside our
comfort zone we develop this comfort
zone
of things that we can say then as long
as the conversation is about that and we
use the phrases that we are able to use
we feel comfortable
but
if i listen to a podcast from france
vancat or a podcast from al jazeera i
don't understand it i understand some
things but not really
so
and yet if i go to my lesson and i work
through it there's so many new words
it's tiring so i retreat back to the
comfort of the mini stores
but i've decided not to do that any
longer i'm going to force myself
and to do that of course the content has
to be a little compelling so again if i
go back to the older lessons
where i paid people to transcribe the
podcast and i have them
in link i can't share them but i can use
them myself
um
it's no longer new it's not
compelling
so i am subscribed to some podcasts
and now
uh i have discovered and this is what
i'm going to demonstrate now as we share
the screen
demonstrate how i use these automatic
transcription
websites or at least i'm trying them
again getting out of my comfort zone it
may be that they're not accurate it
doesn't matter if there's some minor
mistakes it's just for language learning
but if they are totally unusable or not
and these are the things that i'm going
to be exploring so i'm going to
demonstrate to you how this works and
i'll be looking at the questions later
on you can put them there now and i'll
check for them later on
uh so share screen here where are we
okay share screen
okay start screen share so
this is my youtube thing so i'll shut
that down
and here are the
um some of the podcasts that i subscribe
to
so what i do here
okay i still have some check
i haven't done that for a while some
korean
uh at various times i have subscribed to
these
um
podcasts
and
it's sort of like um
a trial and error to figure out how the
all this stuff works but if we take
this podcast here
so then i can do
wait a second i can look here
and i can add it to my franz van cat
playlist
so i do that
duplicates would you like to add or no i
may as well add it i've already put this
in but
um we'll add it just to see what happens
okay
so now if i go to transfer cat
i'll see these podcasts that stock in
there now the problem is these uh
podcasts are in whatever it is they are
video
so i have to convert them into an mp3
file and this is all stuff that i have
learned
getting outside my comfort zone this is
how it is a
you know
discussion dialogue is a
program it
bernard france franz van gaal so i take
this file
and i slide it down and i put it on this
thing here
i'm squeezed let me just hold the sec
here everything is trial and error
so let's go here again i take this i
move it and i park it on my mp3
conversion thing
did that work
at any rate that's what i do i'm not
sure it's going to work this time let's
see
maybe it's happening behind me or
somewhere
at any rate i convert it to an mp3 file
then i park it in desktop
uh then
having done that
close that for a second and then i go to
and i've tried two
one is happy scribe
and you'll see that i've sent them two
um files to transcribe they're both done
and they're available for me to import
into link
and here i have this other one that's
called vocalmatic
back to my description transcriptions
and here i've transcribed this many so i
can just add a new transcript and all i
do
i'm not going to do it here but all i do
is uh well new transcription
so i grab the file from my desktop and i
drag it into here
uh and it takes a few you know 30
seconds depending on the length to uh
upload
then i select the language
these are all the languages that are
available for transcription i've used
arabic lebanon i don't know whether it
works equally well with other arabics so
i choose that
and uh
i guess i could demonstrate like if i
take this file
i don't know how long this file is there
we go you'll see the file is uh
uploading
but i don't want to spend i'm not going
to send it in because i think i've
already done this and i don't want to
use up my free
or whatever package i have
but once this is uploaded
then
you know i can submit
which i won't do
and then of course i can
copy and paste
so i copy it into the import lesson
and uh
you know i just paste the text here
and then i go to upload audio file
collect that audio file from my desktop
give it a title
of course i have to choose
where i'm putting it i'm putting it into
fonts fine cut here i'm not going to do
it
and now i have a lesson that i can study
so my uh goal here
is that i'm going to listen daily to
these um
podcasts whether it be al jazeera or
franz van gaal so they will be topical
uh you know elections in algeria or the
war in yemen so they'll be
you know talking about events in the
middle east it'll be topical up to date
and i think that'll make it more
interesting for me and i'm going to be
well outside my comfort zone for a long
time looking at words never remembering
them feeling that i'm not making any
progress but in fact i will be and i
notice already that i understand more
and more so uh now you are screen
sharing stop
stop screen sharing all right now
i hope you know i sometimes
again get outside your comfort zone
i'm not comfortable with all this modern
technology i'm hoping that you were able
to see
share my screen i noticed i didn't
uh click on a thing called present to
everyone
but we'll see all right so now
uh i'm going to see what sorts of uh so
just to summarize then before we get to
the questions i think it's important to
get outside your comfort zone
uh i keep saying that and yet i've been
guilty of staying for too long into my
comfortable content in arabic so i've
now made
and made the commitment to myself that
i'm going to focus on more difficult
content which makes it more interesting
but it is certainly outside my comfort
zone so
now let's have a look at what we have in
the way of questions
all right now blah blah blah i hope it
works today i hope it's working yeah
sending prayer steve's way
in hopes of working stream today i think
is working how is my language running
family doing today i'm shaking by fear
like my teacher will ask me if i did my
heart
blah blah he is the teacher's not the
lies
ah
oh well i do the same still have a
shortcut
okay hello there greetings from brazil
blah blah blah
uh steve thank you very much for what
you do
until now
what uh teaches rock solid confidence in
language my success i hope so
given what you're saying does language
learning
outside link count is getting outside
the comfort zone of course it does
some less known languages aren't there
yet so there's no harm in trying new
resources of course once you try all
kinds of different things language
learning is an individual
you know journey of exploration
you know the pronunciation comes i don't
think we should worry about it too much
uh but
some things that we can do i did at an
earlier stage with some languages
i would listen to a short snippet the
short paragraph and then try to
immediately try to save myself with an
emphasis on the intonation and
occasionally i would record myself and
hear just how i'm different from
the native speaker you have to hear you
have to hear the language first of all
and that's
you achieve that by doing a lot of
listening and then you have to be aware
of how your pronunciation is different
so
many people are influenced by the
writing so you know uh
we have anna in our office who's from
spain
and to her the word sword s-w-o-r-d
sword because she thought the w is
pronounced don't forget english
you know is not written the way it's
pronounced and so people in language
would like portuguese or spanish where
the where the language is written the
way it's pronounced expect english to
perform the same way it doesn't so you
have to really listen to how the
language is spoken and not rely so much
on what you read but a lot of listening
some listening and repeating and some
recording yourself and comparing
yourself to the native speaker is
helpful and remember to focus on
intonation
uh assuming in experience with language
tutors or exchanges what should one do
in their preparation to reduce speaking
anxiety with online partners
well i don't do any preparation
uh the biggest thing that i do to reduce
anxiety
uh is to do a lot of listening and
reading so that i am likely to
understand a lot of what the tutor says
to me the biggest anxiety is not
understanding the other person i can
struggle if i don't know a word i ask
the tutor she gives it to me
uh which i forget immediately but then
she report
so
the fact that i don't that i'm missing
words and phrases doesn't bother me in
fact it's an opportunity for me to
create
content when i get that report from the
tutor this is learning content on words
that matter to me so that's all good the
biggest problem is when you don't
understand what the other person is
saying and that's why i put so much
emphasis on input listening and reading
as the best way to prepare for speaking
whether in real life or with a tutor
and i just go for it it's a learning
it's a learning opportunity i'm going to
gain
from the exchange and i'm going to gain
from
the words that i receive that i i'm
going to study
i don't get it i don't have anxiety i
hope that's helpful to you
if learner doesn't have a place to
practice to speak and get out of her
comfort zone what can he do get
face to face okay the comfort zone is
not limited to speaking the comfort zone
that i refer to is also about
going to more and more difficult content
a wider and wider variety of content so
that you are expanding your vocabulary
you're getting used to hearing
different speakers different accents
different subject matter
all of that is important now in so far
as speaking if you don't have people to
practice with locally then you have to
look for people online
which is
less
satisfying because
uh very often language partners you know
it's not for sure that they're going to
have interest that they share with you
uh or you have to pay for a tutor
so
i you know if i if i haven't got the
ability to speak i don't worry about it
if i build up my
comprehension ability
um
my
reading ability
i'm preparing myself for so that when i
do get that opportunity
um
i will do better
so
work on the input and then when you do
have an opportunity go for it and if you
are successful in finding a language
partner online so much the better
so hello my name is uh nila stange
thakur i'm from india okay mumbai
greetings
uh
how do i start speaking a language after
learning so many words you just start
speaking and you will struggle you will
struggle everyone struggles
however
my approach is don't start too early if
you have good comprehension
um
you will do better when you start but
you will always struggle
uh okay mp3 converter is not open aha
that could be at any rate that's how i i
just wanted to show you how i do it
uh
uh
or do you think it's because i'm just
curious
okay first of all okay t-shirts i have
no news to report
okay raw in persian
have you occur yeah it's similar to what
happens in japanese
uh but what's unique to persian is that
it's it's simply
an object marker whereas
the sort of particles in japanese
have other functions as well
uh
so
from that point of view i'm quite
comfortable with it because i'm used to
it in japanese
i learned
spoken english my problem is my hindi
language all right what would you
consider
would you consider learning languages as
part of the same family like turkish and
kazakh
like
or at least non-standard languages
spoken same country like okay
i mean
i don't know anything about how close
turkish and kazakh are or japanese to
indonesia
i learn related languages slavic
languages romance languages are the
differences between turkish and kazakh
greater less i have no idea
i'm motivated to learn
a language either because of the history
of the country because i'm going to be
traveling there
uh if i were traveling to kazakhstan or
indonesia i might be interested in
learning for example with arabic i'm
learning standard arabic uh i went to
morocco i didn't really try very hard to
learn moroccan arabic but if i were
obviously if i were to spend months
there i would learn moroccan arabic do
you think writing helps people to speak
and i say i have two hours a day for
learning language one hour of be doing
link and my question is what would you
do with the remaining one hour
um i mean certainly writing is very good
it's time consuming
and i always say okay if i write and
for example on link i can
use the dictation function to write and
i have used it to some extent
in greek
and in arabic to become more familiar
with the alphabet
but of course any it's it's like
it's like this business of the many
stories versus
extensive reading the more you focus on
improving on things that you more or
less can already do the fewer new words
you're acquiring so
it's a choice it depends on how well
you're doing what your level is
but if it were me
uh and if i were fairly well along and i
was spending one hour in link i would
spend one hour reading a book
without looking anything up get into
reading
if i had the opportunity to speak i
would speak
um now understand what we talk about do
you mean that you recognize the words is
that you are able to translate the words
understanding the language means that
you understand
so there are degrees of understanding i
mean obviously if it's your own language
you understand close to 100 percent uh
foreign language your understanding is
going to go from
0 to 10 to 30 to 50 to 70
understanding means
meaning
it means that what you hear
is meaning
i don't deliberately translate the words
to some extent i must be translating but
i don't worry about how much do i
translate how much is like meaning
uh but
understanding the language means the
message that's contained in the words is
meaning
so
nikolas asked you know
how important was money in your choice
of professions
and well how would you describe your
relationship with money
uh as a according to your book
fall you followed your heart i mean
of course this is an interesting
question you know what is money for
money buys you things
that make you feel happy happy or secure
or
or or whatever so you certainly do need
a certain amount of money otherwise you
can't buy food you can't look after your
family blah blah blah
uh however
uh certainly in my
choice of professions i made moves which
were risky which maybe might have
threatened my family's livelihood but i
felt that they were
going to be better for me in terms of
life's adventure so it's again like it
gets back to this comfort zone
if you are in a job that you don't like
but it provides you with an income
you're in a comfort zone you can buy
what you need to buy and everything is
comfortable but you're bored
so
where i have been faced with that
choice i have always gone
for the risk
uh now the risk has to be a calculated
risk you can't just do anything but
so i think one has to even with regard
to money
uh money can be a cage
like anything else it's a comfort zone
if people have a solid income and they
don't try and push themselves beyond
that it can also be a limiting thing
because you only have the one life to
explore what language have you learned
is most expressive i know four languages
and i think arabic is i've expressed an
idea actually in fewer words when using
harvard yeah
my own impression is that and i have
varying degrees of knowledge of 20
languages all languages are equally
expressive
all languages can express the exact same
thoughts now i'm not far enough along in
arabic
to tell you whether arabic is uniquely
expressive
but i can tell you that in the languages
that i have learned that range from
romance languages slavic languages asian
languages
whatever they're all equally expressive
they all have their own little
idiosyncrasies they all have their own
you know aspects that i find appealing
certain things that they express
particularly well but unbalanced
all equally expressive and and you know
i often hear people say like our
language is the best our language is the
richest
i i just when people start saying that
to me i just so said yeah whatever
uh i have not found that to be the case
short stories have lots of unknown words
for me should i start from some other
easier content instead or should i force
myself out of my comfort zone i mean
that's your individual
choice
uh i have found the many stories good to
get the sort of basic structure the most
frequent verbs and then you have to find
something that hopefully is compelling
push yourself out of your comfort zone
for me short stories in other words
fiction
is more difficult than non-fiction so
and i'm also less interested
i am more interested in history and
politics so typically in all of the
languages i have learned once i get
outside my comfort zone i tend to move
into non-fiction
uh
typically either news commentary current
of
that nature
how do you succeed
in not forgetting the languages you
already know while learning a new one
well of course you do forget to some
extent
but
uh
i know for example i've left korean now
for a while
um
when i go back to it very quickly i will
go beyond the level i was at
i have always found that neglecting a
language and going back to it
obviously i've fallen back a few steps
gotten a bit rusty but very quickly i
get back to where i was and as i
rediscover things and relearn things i
end up knowing those things better i'm
even finding that this week going back
and forth between persian and arabic
as i
you know sometime this afternoon i have
to switch back to persian
and it's rusty all of a sudden it's been
three four days and already i've
forgotten this but very quickly i'm back
to where i was so i don't worry about it
and you know i kind of look at
my uh i have a database and link i have
content that i've done i have stories i
have words
that have been saved that are now yellow
or known or whatever
but i have a similar database in my
brain and i just have to go back to it
refresh it and i'm right back to where i
am further
what would you say is your best language
other than english french steve please
please save the internet by subscribing
to pewdiepie no thank you
uh
i think one of the things about the
internet
and the mobile learning is we have to
restrict uh
you know
limit the distractions and i'm not at
all interested in pewdiepie
uh
censor and you'll make true okay don't
win okay
want another chinese video okay i will
but i want to get through
uh
my 90-day challenge okay so
senior bonnet georgia
is there a right time to move on to
difficult time for example if i'm
beginner and i'm reading many stories
for a while and then i want to challenge
you okay you have to explore everything
is about exploring see how you like the
more difficult content
and i think there is a period when we
initially we do maybe all many stories
are easy content and then we do
10 more difficult content and then we go
20
and we just continue that way
have you ever wanted to immigrate to a
non-english speaking country in
retirement or have you gotten enough of
that through your experience
i mean i'm indifferent and don't forget
i don't immigrate or expatriate myself
i have a family so i have to consider my
wife i have to consider where my kids
are
all of these things i mean for me if i
lived in a non
uh english-speaking environment and went
down and had a coffee in the morning and
chatted with the locals and read the
local paper and kind of lived you know
in a
new environment i would enjoy doing that
and i i have to some extent done that my
visit to leave in ukraine
uh
you know week in prague
um
and uh yeah i i like to do that but you
know
i have a lot of things that i have to
consider
hello steve if we are outside our
comfort zone learning with advanced
material you don't think that we learn
advanced level and have a okay so
don't forget uh yeah i mean any content
the most frequently used words are going
to be a high percentage
of the content
in the many stories the high frequency
words might be 85-90
in
say non-fiction it might be
75
in you know literature it might be less
than that
uh so they keep on coming up
and in the content that i'm we're
looking at now in al jazeera or france
bad cat the words that i'm coming across
are things like you know election
investigation uh conference uh uh you
know candidate whatever things of that
nature which are fairly common
uh i think the really rare words are
more likely to show up in literature
uh so as long as you're pushing yourself
outside your comfort zone into
things that are of interest to you
then presumably the uh vocabulary there
will be of interest to you
she's already here you know france your
father permission
i encourage that burn
i love
okay
he's from normandy okay i have spent a
lot of time in love
and uh he's uh you know uh speaking a
little bit every day and but don't
neglect the listening and reading when i
was in japan i was surrounded by
japanese but i just listened listen
listen i pushed myself
to i remember i got an nhkl nhk which is
the japanese broadcasting system there
i got a um a cassette tape on the
history of the showa era which i
listened to over and over and over again
even when i didn't understand it
and uh
you need to
if you had to give your younger self a
tip according to language learning which
would it be and if you could change
something about your language or your
journey what would it be
um
you know it's been fairly consistent
once i got onto chinese and i realized
and this is 50 years ago that massive
listening and reading
was going to get my brain used to the
language faster than anything else
that's kind of been what i have done
um
you know
technology is different now there's many
more
apps or sources of content i don't have
to go scouring bookstores as i did in
hong kong looking for
books with um
you know vocabulary lists after every
uh
you know lesson
so
no nothing i can think of right away may
you all have a great deal of jesus jesus
is phonetically similar to spanish do
you think this sounds
oh
greek is extremely similar to spanish
especially the spanish spoken in spain
it has
uh
many
similar uh
sounds the the hota like her the
the vowels are the same the heavy s is
the same very very similar
and i'm in vancouver
uh
i'm learning greek and i'm spanish and i
can answer that yes you are right for
sure hello from turkey
you think it's better to learn first the
meaning of the kanji before trying to
memorize how to spell them better learn
both things at the same time
i mean
i was in the fortunate position of
having to learn chinese before i started
japanese so i knew that kanji at least
their chinese pronunciation and meaning
uh i don't know what you mean by how to
spell the kanji you perhaps mean how to
pronounce them
uh
i think there's a
i can only refer to my own experience
and that was that a deliberate
effort to learn the most common kanji
uh whether that be 500 or a thousand is
worth it and then you'll recount you'll
forget them and you encounter them again
and as you encounter them again you
review them again and so that this
gradual
uh expansion
of uh your familiarity with the kanji
but you will continue to have to focus
on learning the country
so
how do you
you know i don't worry the question is
how do you sort of keep the new
vocabulary you learn you can't no matter
how well you think you've learned it
you're still going to forget it i find
lots of it some sticks right away and
some you just keep on forgetting and
forgetting and forgetting and
my experience is the only way
to get that vocabulary to stick is just
to keep on listening and reading keep on
and i will occasionally review as i turn
the page and link
uh i thought i do that regularly um but
i think one shouldn't
i think one of the things is it's
natural to forget the vocabulary if you
relearn it
forget it again relearn it it will
eventually stick some sticks faster than
others have you met any for a me between
the arabic and persian yet
i mean the arabic words in persian are
so helpful
there's a lot of them i don't know what
the number is 30 maybe
uh it helps me
to learn the two at the same time
uh sometimes the meaning is a little
different i've never worried about false
friends
all it is you get to know the meaning of
the word in the new language
because you see it in more and more
different contexts so i don't assume
because i've looked up the meaning of a
word
that i now know that word i'm gonna have
to see that word in so many different
contexts and eventually it's gonna
click for me but
even if the if these are false friends
it's easier to remember even a false
friend than a word that has no
connection to anything that you've seen
before so i find that the arabic loan
words in persian to be very helpful
uh two way to begin so a question here
i'm learning english but i want to know
chinese go for it and a lot of the
chinese learning material is based on
english so you could continue your
involvement with english
here is something presumably in tagalog
and say oh
i recommend to learn the meaning of the
kanji first as you learn the right you
can learn okay
how do you go fast from b1 to b2 in a
language i have never gone quickly from
b1 to b2 that's the longest stretch b1
to b2 in my opinion
uh
d1 is that sense of
the language now you understand some
things you're able to say some things
d2 is you're really quite good in the
language and there's only one way and
that's lots of listening and reading and
eventually lots of speaking you need to
put in the time and that's why here
again it's important to get outside your
comfort zone you will never get from b1
to b2 if you stay with you know learner
material beginner material you have to
force yourself into real content
i feel like i know you're fluent i've
only been studying for a month and a
half but the tones of soda gram phones
maybe i'm just being pessimistic a month
and a half is nothing i've been at my
arabic for a year i still feel like
nowhere
takes time to learn languages and
especially chinese where the tones are
an issue and the characters are an issue
so don't be so impatient that's my only
advice
say oh god this is still going hello
steve what would you say is your best
language other than english i already
answered that it's french
i have a veto all in spanish and i
really want to start learning german
please give me an approach a method that
to keep improving my spanish and
learning german as well
you might expect this as my reply but
get on link and you can keep them both
going right now i have all the languages
that i've learned at length
and i can flip back to them anytime i
want
how many of your family and friends have
you gotten to regularly use link
basically
other than mark who works with me on it
none
uh i would say
i shouldn't say none
i do come across friends who say gee
thank you and i'm enjoying it and stuff
like that
but a handful
compared to all the people that i speak
to who say yeah i want to learn spanish
i want to learn something other and i
say well here go and use this
but then again
how many people go into a bookstore and
thumb through the
language books section
and then maybe don't buy a book
or buy a book and go home and never open
the book
or open the book and do the first two
chapters and never get beyond that so
the fact the matter is that learning a
language while it's not difficult it
does require
a certain level
of commitment
to that
is
watching cbc french help
okay i mean
personally watching tv video to me it's
kind of background
it's not it helps a little
but i find that you have to have a high
degree of comprehension
and so therefore
if i were going to use video
uh i would go to youtube
find some video with subtitles and
import that into link as a lesson so
then you can read the text
you can download the audio to listen to
and you build up your comprehension the
other problem with with video now of
course it's the news it's a different
story but if you're watching
videos and sitcoms it's fun
but those are less language intense than
pure audio
so i always find that audio and reading
listening is
a
more effective way of learning a
language but watching movies movies and
video and certainly if i were
living in canada and i wanted to learn
french i would turn on the french
channel it's a good background
how long do you think would take
brazilian to learn spanish
from a1 to b2 it depends how hard he
goes at it but uh
three to six months
uh the biggest thing for the brazilian
is to stop being a brazilian like he has
to visualize him or herself as a spanish
speaker accent-wise just totally dive
into it
all right
all right
this chinese is too difficult
all these people who find language is
difficult you just got to stay with it
the brain learns but it learns slowly
uh uh
how did i know it was tagalog it looked
like the girl like i could be wrong
there's many many languages in the
philippines but i'm assuming
that it's together
uh does your level matter steve i've
been following for five years it's
fantastic you're doing these lives i've
learned two languages utilizing your
advice tonight thank you
and that's what's happening
okay
and sorry that's not about did it for me
what i've
all right steve when you need someone to
speak to for hindu and punjabi it's next
on my list once i am moving eastward so
once i get past the i want to do the
turkish and then i have the feeling that
if i get good enough in the
persian
that's going to slide me into urdu and
maybe hindi we will see
oftentimes you are improving and don't
realize it yes
uh what kind of content do you want to
be able to use chinese
does knowing the meaning and writing of
the top 300 use for
all right
wanted that's
okay
i don't know do you have any intention
about turkish among language girls yes
definitely
uh but you know two at once is is a bit
much but i am definitely gonna move to
turkish there's also a lot of turkish
cereals on netflix do you believe in a
tpr approach how to get tutored to see
that way i don't know how you get a
teacher to teach that way
you know
i know of tprs teaching proficiency
through reading and
storytelling i'm not entirely clear on
how tpr works uh you would have to
google i can't tell you
uh definitely a personal help with every
hint okay
all right i'm gonna stop it here i gotta
prepare i guess uh i'm gonna prepare for
my arabic tutor by
listening in arabic get my brain turned
over to arabic so thank you everyone and
we'll see you next time
bye for now